Hi data2100 students. In this
video, I want to introduce
you to top and distinct. We term
these as analytical functions
that we can use in SQL. So
first off, let's talk about
the top function and top percent.
So if I ever wanted to say, show
me the number of guests that were
the top five oldest guests or
top five youngest guests, I could
do that by using the top function
so the top function heavily
relies on the order by to say am I
going to show the top five oldest
guests or the top five youngest
guests so all it does is it basically
cuts off the top five records
of output and that is all that is
included in what is outputted to
you as the user therefore because
it just looks at the top five
records it is so important as what
order those records are in, okay?
So let's go ahead and do an
example. So I have given you some
examples and but before we do
that let's just start off with
this example right here. So
we're going to show the top five
guest ID, last name, first name,
and age from the guest table.
So I'm going to go ahead and say
select star from guest. Okay,
and I'll return that.
All right, perfect. So now I
want to see their guest ID,
first name, last name, and age.
So once I run this, I can see
here now I'm limiting the number
of fields that are returned
to me. But this time I want to
output just the top five. So
if I was to add in top five
right here, and I run this,
you're going to notice that just
five records are output to me.
Okay, so I only have five records
now at this point, which isn't
very helpful because I don't even
know how these at this point are
sorted by. It looks like just by the
guest ID that Christian Willis is
guest ID number one. Well, that's
not answering my question, right?
Let's say that my question is,
show me the top five oldest guess.
Well, this isn't answering my question.
So what I need to do is,
instead of just saying select
top five and just leaving it
at that, I need to order by
age, and I want the highest
age at the top down to the
lowest age. So I'm going to
say order by age descending.
So greatest, if you
will, age at the top to
the least. And I'll go
ahead and hit enter.
And now I can see here that
I have all of these ages
of these different guests
that are outputting to me. So
I can see here that these
are all 76-year-old guests.
And according to my data,
those are the oldest guests
that we have. Now, if
I wanted to switch this
around and say, actually,
I want to show the top five
youngest guests, all I would need
to do is just change what I'm
ordering by. Instead of descending,
I say ascending, and I run this.
Okay, so now I see that I have
all these two-year-old guests
that are returning to me. So I
can do top five, I can do top ten.
you can do any number that you
want here. I can say top 25.
It's not just five. Okay. But generally
you're going to see
questions like top five.
In this case, we're going to do top 25.
Perfect. So here is the top 25 guests
returned to me based upon their age.
All right, awesome. The next
thing that we're going to learn
is about showing unique values
using the distinct keyword.
So if I ever wanted to figure
out what are the unique first
names, meaning non-repeating,
so if I have three employees
named Reagan, all spelt the
same, which is really important,
and I said select distinct employee
first name, then instead of
three Reagans all showing up, again,
they have to be spelt the same,
I'm only going to have
one Reagan show up. So
I'm just looking for
unique or distinct values.
So let's go ahead and answer one
of our review questions that I give
you in the example, or one of our
example questions that I give you.
So we're going to output
the unique last names of
customers who have a season
pass. So I'm going to go ahead
and say select star, and
we're going to do from guest.
Okay, we're just going to always
start off with that. So the unique
last names of customers who have
a season pass. So first off,
I'm going to get rid of any
records that I do not want in my
output. So they have to have a season
pass. So over here in my season
pass there needs to be a Y in
that season pass column for yes.
So you have to say where season pass
equal to Y. okay now i'll run this
and now i can see here that all
of these guests have a season pass
now i only want to look at unique
last names okay so right now if i
was just to say uh select a last name
and i run this now i can see here
that i have like owens is only here
at least one time to begin with
then i have underwood underwood uh
carter carter stephen smith oliver
oliver Morales Morales but this time
if I only want to output the unique
last names I say select distinct
last name I go ahead and run this
and now I can see here that all of
these last names that are outputting
to me are all unique there's none
that are repeating okay and again
unique is termed as though they are
spelt the same they are the exact
same characters right as what um
any others are. So if I have, this
is where data quality comes in and
it's very important that all atoms
that are spelt this way, right,
are input that way. So all of my
atoms, there's, when I look at
unique last names, any atoms are all
condensed into one last name to output
that unique last name of atoms. All
right, the last two here output the
five warmest days in the season.
So this is going to, I'm going
to be looking at my day table.
So I'll say select star from day.
As a reminder, day is what
looks at the attributes of that
day. So here I have the date,
the day of the week, the price,
the holiday. So I'll put the
five warmest days. So I'm going
to be looking at this high
temperature. So I'm going to say
select a D date and let's look
at high temp to begin with.
I'm going to go ahead and run
this and I can see that I have D
-date and high temp. So five warmest
days. So I need to now order
by a high temp and we will do
five warmest days. So I want it
to be descending. I want the highest
values at the top, right, for
my top function. So you can see
that I have high temperature.
The highest values are at
the top. So I'm going to
output the five warmest days.
I'm going to say top five.
You go ahead and run this now.
And we can see here that I get April 8th,
2023, March 21st, 2023. And those are my
five warmest days of the season.
Now I only want to look for
days. I don't want the high
temp included in the output
because I'm just looking for
five warmest days in the season.
As we learn more SQL, it's
going to become really important
that we don't put anything in
the select clause that we don't
want to be included, that we
don't want as an output field.
So just make sure that we're not
adding extra fields here to be included
in my select because that can
become an issue as we learn more
advanced techniques. So these are
the five warmest days in the season.
Now down here finally I
want to look at output the
bottom 10% coldest days
in the season. So looking
at my select, let's see,
let's just do select top.
Well, let's just do another
select star from day.
Go ahead and run this.
So I'll put the bottom 10% coldest
days in the season. So again,
I'm looking at high temperature
and I want to say here from day and
I want to order by high temp
descending. okay because I want, oh
ascending, I want the coldest
temperatures at the top. Okay so here
I have high temperature is negative
four. So that would be one of
my coldest days. And this time
instead I want top 10%. Well if we
look here I have 120 records output
to me. So I want to say select
top 10% D date and I'll say high
temp for now. What this is going to
do is it's going to return to
me, what's 10% of 120? I hope you
said 12 rows. So you're right, it's
going to output to me 12 rows of
data, and now I get the bottom 10
% coldest days. So December 27th,
January 1st, then I'm going to
again delete out high temperature.
Therefore, I am just returning those
top 10% D-dates of the coldest days
in the season. All right, I hope
this was helpful to you in learning
remember top and order by go hand
in hand and distinct helps us find
unique values thank you take care